[Music]
the beauty brigade from ocean state
surprised fans at a special screening of
their film at Manhattan last night and
Nichelle Turner's joining us right now
from New York where she saw all that
glamour of those how were the girls easy
oh man the ladies were fierce with the
fashions to her best believe it now
this crews chemistry is off the charts
so when I sat down with the cast it was
clear they came to play and in Cate
Blanchett's case serenades right to it
Cate sure knows how to make an entrance
with rapper aquafina by her side
followed by oceans 8 leader Sandra
Bullock together they have flipped the
switch on the heist franchise I came out
of this movie with a big old grin on my
face hard good you know I just felt
really good about stealing just like
seeing this new group of women together
it just felt good it did yeah yeah
despite what you might hear Sandra says
her all-star pack of thieves came to set
with zero ego here they are just last
night cracking each other up
it always takes a while to get into the
groove of anything you don't know if
someone's gonna be comfortable working
one way or another way and after the
first couple of weeks everything just
kind of settled just settled yeah yeah
and you realize there wasn't one person
who didn't want the other one to succeed
and I had to clear something else up you
see the ladies had what you might call a
lively group text chat during owns
production but when we spoke to co-star
Rihanna she was curious why it went so
quiet we have live another tech scene
the movie unless they like took me off
with a girl chat now we're worried about
being hacked it's all delicious Celeste
as I said let's just go through the run
last night we read through all our texts
to each other remember that moment we
said and delete made us delete them all
there no longer exists hackers
[Music]